Оси своє з'їдають, а того,
що нам залишають, нам досить.
Природа жива,
і всі повинні бути ситі.
Оса теж жива істота,
і хай собі насолоджується тим,
що вона з'їсть частину нашого винограду.
Для винограду це місце прямо золоте.
Як кажуть, виноград і ягода
повинні страждати.
Тоді можна отримати хороше вино.
Тут колись був пустир,
ми перебуваємо на схилах кар'єру.
Ґрунти тут каштанові, важкі.
Червона глина переходить у вапняки.
І на них майже нічого
не можна було вирощувати.
Лише виноград показав дуже якісні ягоди.
Вони були насичені.
Вони були ароматні.
Вони були великої цукристості.
І такі обставини нас спонукали звернутися
до цього питання — виноробства.
Багато виноградників у Криму розкорчували.
Іде знищення виноградників,
наскільки я знаю.
Наш мікроклімат і Крим — майже однакові.
Набір температур однаковий що у Криму, що в нас.
Ми повторюємо лінійку кримських вин.
На жаль, Крим зараз окупований.
Тому ми вийшли з винами
кримськими на ринок України.
Таврія славилася коньячним домом у Каховці, шато князя
Трубецького, нами та господарством у Білозерці.
Десь з кінця 1990-х років я повернувся
обличчям до світу вина.
І я побачив, що це —
такий глибокий, широкий світ,
який потребує багато знань.
Вичерпати і все пізнати неможливо.
Усі зони, де вирощується виноград,
мають свої особливості.
Сукупність цих особливостей називають
французьким словом «теруар».
Унікальність, наприклад,
нашого теруару, у тому,
що ми маємо велике водосховище
перед нами — Каховське водосховище.
І це для нас дуже позитивно,
адже ми маємо баланс температур,
який дозволяє нам мати
дуже гарні кондиції для винограду.
Також у нас крутий правий схил Дніпра.
Це дає додаткові гарні умови
для визрівання винограду.
І ми маємо дуже гарну
мінеральність у ґрунті,
це теж дуже важливо для винограду.
Завжди можна відчути
у відтінках і присмаках вина.
На півдні України умови сприятливі
для вирощування винограду.
Виноградна лоза добре дозріває.
Виноград має високі показники якості
завдяки цьому географічному розташуванню.
Коли 30 років тому мені тут землю дали,
і коли кілки забили,
мовляв, ось це твої 50 гектарів,
то ми сюди прийшли і зробили
з очерету такий шалаш.
Ми жили, потім охоронець був тут,
кавуни посадили,
а вони росли тут погано.
І так назвали його «куренем».
Збили палиці,
на них накидали соломи,
туди можна зайти,
від дощу сховатися.
І там прохолодно навіть було.
І потім вже думали...
А що тут думати: як вже є курінь,
отже, і торгова марка «Курінь».
Так воно й залишилось.
Це було дуже давно,
десь у 1880-х роках.
Лев Голіцин запропонував князю Трубецькому,
який володів цими землями,
саме тут створити виноробню
і висадити виноградники.
Для того, щоб ризикнути і створити
тут виноробне господарство, мало було повірити.
Треба було пройти
цей великий шлях для того,
щоб зробити перше вино.
Перший результат,
який він отримав у 1900 році,
коли була в Парижі всесвітня виставка,
він зі своїм вином «Рислінг» отримав
єдину за всю історію гран-прі.
З того часу він зрозумів,
що так, і теруар правильний,
і вина тут можна робити дуже гарні.
Він почав дуже швидко
розбудовувати виноробню.
І збудував собі замок,
в якому поселився і став жити.
Для того, щоб зробити
виноградний саджанець,
потрібні підщепа і прищепа,
якщо це щеплений саджанець.
Підщепа — це корінь,
те, на чому прививається
культурний сорт.
І прищепа — це сам культурний сорт,
який потрібен, щоб він ріс.
Вирощування саджанців —
це дуже копіткий процес.
Для того, щоб виростити саджанець,
потрібно зробити близько
170 технологічних операцій.
Якщо брати в повному обсязі,
то потрібен один рік,
щоб виростити лозу.
Потім цю лозу зрізати,
зробити щеплення,
і це буде ще один рік.
І на осінь другого року вже
виходить якісний саджанець.
Так! А чому не прийшли?
Та завтра.
Добре, давай, нехай ідуть,
почали масове збирання
винограду, так.
Так, поїхали.
Їдемо на збирання Мерло.
Потрібно збирати вранці.
Збираємо буквально навіть при світлі,
з 5-ої до 9-ої ранку,
доки сонце не вийшло.
Бажано, щоб не було дощу,
це по-перше.
І хороший настрій у збирачів, так.
[сміється]
Хороший сорт Мерло.
Бачите, є хороше гроно.
Міцно тримається, так?
Нормально?
Ви вручну робите
чи ножиком підрізаєте?
Ні, вручну.
Ну хто як звик.
А ти один сьогодні чи з дружиною?
Привіт!
А, з сином, так?
Добре.
Це не є промислове виробництво.
Сімейне господарство невеличке.
Вони більше приділяють уваги
своїм виноградникам.
Застосовується багато ручної праці,
все ж таки вона більш акуратна.
Ручний збір винограду.
Знаєте, борщ можна зробити
на кухні для декількох людей,
а можна зробити в їдальні
для сотні людей.
Який ви будете їсти?
Будинок, де зараз знаходиться і ресторан наш,
і рецепція нашого готелю, —
це був будинок самої виноробні.
Одне вікно трохи нижче за інші —
то це був в'їзд.
І сюди на конях завозили
на переробку виноград.
Все це автентичне і справжнє,
і навіть ми лишили для того,
щоб наші гості могли подивитись і побачити
ці декілька плиток часів Трубецького.
Отака була підлога у виноробні.
Це трошки ми вже відновлювали,
але ось історично ми все лишили.
І перебуваємо на глибині
-13 метрів від так званого нуля.
Ми маємо унікальні можливості для того,
щоб довго витримувати вино в бочках.
На вулиці зараз +30 [градусів].
У нижній галереї ми тримаємо температуру
десь, мабуть, +15 градусів.
У верхній галереї може
на один-два градуси вище.
Але ця температура дуже важлива,
і вона стабільна протягом року.
Ще дуже важлива вологість.
Вологість повинна бути
не дуже високою, не вище 90%.
Але й не нижче 60%,
адже це дуже важливо
для зберігання вина в бочках.
Ми маємо хорошу експозицію в тому,
що наша переробка розміщена
прямо на винограднику.
Тому, зібравши невелику
кількість ящиків,
ми швиденько привозимо
на виноробню.
Воно не встигає під сонцем нагрітися.
Одразу кидаємо у дробарку його.
Хороший урожай.
Дуже ароматна ягода, солодка.
Буде хороше вино,
ми думаємо.
[сміється]
І працюємо над цим!
Так, що у нас,
кипить?
Кипить, так?
Пішли сюди.
Ваги готові,
все готове.
І виноград піде зараз на переробку.
Це дробарка.
Вона переробляє більше тонни
винограду за годину.
Зараз виноград прямо йде
у вініфікатор на настойці.
Червоний сорт.
Тут роблять щеплення.
Береться лоза дикого сорту винограду.
Береться лоза культурного сорту.
І робиться щеплення.
Машинка називається «Омега».
Вона робить такий виріз,
омега-подібний.
Це називається «прищепа».
Те, що ми культурне
прививаємо на дике.
Оскільки дике більш
до хвороб стійке.
І стійкіше до морозу, посухи тощо.
Ми виробляємо вино винятково
з власного винограду.
Шардоне, Піно блан, Рислінг,
Совіньйон блан, Аліготé.
З червоних — це відомий вже всім
сорт Каберне совіньйон,
Мерло, Каберне фран,
Пті вердо, Мальбек, Сірá.
Маємо дуже розвинені виноградники,
десь близько 165 гектарів.
Раз на два-три роки
ми садимо нові виноградники.
Наповнюватися колекція
почала десь з 1950 року.
Що за вина тут знаходяться?
Ті, які мають потенціал
до довгого витримування у пляшці.
Наприклад, для білих вин
це відповідна кислотність,
а для червоних вин —
це відповідні таніни,
які згодом м'якшають,
але зберігають вино
довгі-довгі роки у пляшці.
Коли вино пробуєш через 10-15 років
і бачиш, що воно живе, — це класно.
Творча робота,
тому що хто в ній працює,
той завжди в пошуку.
У пошуку того,
як зробити кращий продукт.
Зараз, хвилиночку.
Ну, тут, у бочках, знаходяться
наші вина, вже готові.
Червоні десертні вина знаходяться
у дерев'яних бочках.
Білі вина знаходяться
у бочках з нержавійки.
Вони тут доходять.
Тут знаходиться «Іршаї олівер».
Тут знаходиться наша «Софія»,
яка дозріває в бочках,
а також «Іршаї» і «Мускат степу».
Ми маємо декілька пляшок
з часів ще Трубецького.
Це маленькі пляшки від вина, з вином.
Ми не відкорковуємо ці пляшки.
Певно, не має значення,
яке там вино.
Але те, що ми маємо пляшки,
які збереглися за ці 120 років,
ми можемо показати,
як вони виглядали, які вони були.
І трошки, може,
торкнутись того часу,
який вже дуже-дуже давно минув.
У світі ще мода — мати своє шато.
У нас багато людей купують
свої виноробні і на них не працюють.
Просто передають управління.
Я вважаю,
що це неправильно,
бо господар повинен сам
бути у своєму шато.
Шато — це така справа,
спілкування з людьми ще.
Треба бути готовим до цього.
Так би мовити,
це буде «зациклений цикл»,
ти виробив вино
і сам підніс його людям.
Дуже багато людей приїжджає.
Люди різні, багато історій.
Хтось щось розказує, тебе слухає.
У житті спілкування з людьми —
це, мабуть, найголовніше.
Людина, яка хоче робити вино,
повинна починати спочатку.
Тобто мати землю,
висадити виноградник,
самому бачити,
як він виросте.
Винятково зі свого винограду
починати робити вино.
І потім вже давати на суд
спільноти те, що він зробив.
Ця філософія мені приємна.
Ці малі винороби,
які мають натхнення,
це мені дуже імпонує,
і ми завжди готові підтримати їх,
обмінюватися досвідом.
Ми можемо бути провідною
в Європі державою.
Тому що ми можемо робити
прекрасні десертні вина і сухі вина.
Перспектива України дуже велика.
В усіх виноробних країнах:
Франції, Італії, Іспанії, наприклад,
населення дуже патріотичне
до своїх вин.
У нас такого немає.
Тому це треба ще ментально,
щоб якось ці процеси пройшли,
світогляд у цій частині змінився.
Тепер потрібно виноробам про себе
заявляти, робити якісний продукт.
Ну й держава повинна також
якийсь вже виробити бренд,
що це вино України.
Вина Бессарабії вже на слуху десь.
Вина Таврії — теж.
Можливо, це об'єднувати,
ну, треба думати про це.
І цей бренд піднімати,
заявляти у світі про себе!
Я вкладаю частину
своєї душі в цю справу.
Я роблю її чесно.
Якщо я кажу «робота для душі»,
то, мабуть, одним із видів такої
діяльності людини є виробництво вина.
Це справа мого життя.
Я присвятив цьому господарству
практично все своє життя.
Це моя, як-то кажуть,
улюблена робота.
Я люблю Україну.
Я хотів би,
щоб кожен українець мав щастя:
кожен день тримати в руках бокал вина.
І це буде, мабуть, людина щаслива.
Я думаю, це буде показувати
тоді й культуру нації,
і достаток нації, і настрій.